if you look at a galaxy and you look at
how stars are moving around the galaxy
they should only be able to move so fast
that the gravity inside the galaxy can
hold them going that fast and if if
something goes faster in a galaxy it'll
fly off just like imagine you're holding
somebody's hand on the playground and
you start spinning faster and faster and
then you like your sweaty hands lose
grip so we look at a galaxy and we see
how much matter is there we're like i
can see a lot of brightness so there's
five billion stars you measure how fast
those stars are moving you calculate how
fast they should be moving and you find
that many of the stars in the universe
are moving way faster than they should
be based off of how much
matter is there to hold you know
basically the hands on the playground
they should be flying off into space but
they're not they're staying in orbit the
theory we've come up with is that
there's extra matter there that we
cannot see and we've called it dark
matter